so johnny depp have you met any royalty
along the way
yeah i did yeah yeah uh
prince charles and um
the other one
that one
listen i mean uh what happens when she
comes home and says you know dad i've
spent 14 years admiring your body art
[Laughter]
what do we do then johnny
my fear is that she'll
she'll bring someone home that she's
been admiring his body
well
sure
one night there was i guess uh don
johnson was was one of hunter's uh
neighbors up up near where he lived
and um
this is gonna be great wherever this
goes i have a feeling it's gonna be
great
oh it's good
[Laughter]
uh 100 it was about three in the morning
hunter said uh
johnson's just called he's coming over
we must ambush him
you know and when you're with hunter
it's not like you go what you basically
just go well of course we should
and so
we we um we grabbed some weapons
and we loaded them up
and we we sort of uh
snuck outside and hid behind bushes
on either side of the driveway so that
when johnson came
pulling in
we started firing up into the air
um
pulling the trigger as quickly as we
possibly could
he didn't come in
do you like your ass
wow
like it
i accept it okay
all right
what is your favorite oh what is your
favorite swear word
ass
his name in german is that what it is
hair belieber bieber i know
i was kind of struck with that word you
know i was doing a press conference
for i think it was for rango and uh
out of nowhere one of the journalists in
the audience asked me
if i was a belieber
and i thought maybe he'd had some sort
of
but i
yeah
that would not be a bad guess
uh here's more express about her
and
see
and this next audio you would think no
how can he look like this
and here you go there he is
may i say one thing yes
someone has a lot of time on their hands
you enjoy playing with barbie dolls
well
not as much as i used to
well yeah yeah i know he was very
unpredictable in a lot of i mean in
every way possible the first time i met
him i was i happened to be in
aspen in this was december of 94.
happened to be an aspen i got an
invitation from a mutual friend said
would you like to meet hunter come to
the
woody creek tavern at uh you know
midnight or something
so i
so i go to the woody creek tavern i make
my way to the as far back in the places
i can you know the back wall just to
kind of
be invisible
and then at around 1 30.
the front door
bursts open and
i literally saw sparks
but sparks
and
then i saw people
like throwing themselves out of the way
and this kind of sea you know opening
the parting of the sea and people
jumping and diving and hurling
themselves to safety
and then i heard out of my way you
bastards
and um
as he got closer i realized that he had
a three-foot cattle prod in his left
hand ah
and a and a taser in his right sure
yeah
just trying to make friends
[Music]
but he um
uh when uh when i spoke with adam mckay
and owen burke and they were talking to
me about doing it they said how would
you like to make a feature film in four
days because we have to get it ready for
the iowa caucus or something and you
know what how would you like to play
donald trump i had no idea
i mean how do you it's very difficult
you've never imitated him before never
mind i just decided
at a party or something they said oh
that's great we should make a movie
around this no
can you see me imitating people at
parties no
but it's so good it doesn't seem i mean
it seems like something that you really
you at least had a running start on well
i got a feel for him because he's
sensational
absolutely fabulous
have you heard from him
did you get any feedback from him
stopped calling me he did
[Music]
do you live uh are you spending time in
venice
italy
yes
yeah i have yeah yeah do you own
property there no no i don't yeah okay
there's a strange rumor that i do but
there is a strange rumor that's what i
was alluding to yeah people say you see
that johnny depp owns that and lives
right there yeah no i wish i did but i
don't yeah it's a nice city uh it's but
it's it's a little sad because it's uh
like so many of these it's a dying city
there's really other than tourism
there's no no the culture is all
vanishing
yeah well there's certainly nothing you
can get good out of that water
yeah that's right uh what was al like
but that was a good combination for you
that was fantastic i mean al is you know
he's a legend he's uh he's al pacino
he's an amazing actor certainly but you
know the one thing i didn't
really know about
pacino prior to
to shooting was that he was certifiably
insane
oh really you've seen the paperwork
apparently
how does that manifest itself uh he had
you know he like uh he's a he's a he's a
joke he likes to tell him tell jokes so
yeah he likes to tell jokes and he liked
to tell me this one
specific joke over and over
and uh
i really didn't understand it
didn't get the joke i didn't get the
joke yeah and he thought it was your
problem that you didn't get the joke
absolutely yeah yeah yeah yeah and we
definitely thought it was my problem so
he keeps wearing you down with the same
joke inflicted it upon me and i could
feel like
you know
iq points dropping yeah
yeah the greater the pressure the dumber
you feel like yeah you know go kind of
jell-o-like yeah did you ever
understand the joke
i finally figured it out yeah what do
you remember the joke yeah okay
here's al used to uh he'd lean over and
he'd go
john
skeleton
goes into a bar
orders a beer
and a mop
[Music]
but i mean yeah i know on a loop yeah
over and over and over again
and did don ever like get a hold of you
and insult you did he i mean i know you
guys spoke and stuff but did he let you
have it no well
see if
all i wanted was to be razzed by don
rickles right yeah i was i've been
waiting for years and got nothing he was
always so sweet
and at the new york thing uh where we
were out to it was like a roast or
something yeah it was a tribute yeah
right so i i ran backstage to go see don
before he was coming out
i run back
real quick and uh he's sitting in a
chair and i said i said hey don i just
want to let you know you know i'm here
and wish you luck and everything he goes
he goes john
you're here
and you're not late
that's a pretty good don rickles by the
way thanks
you ride you don't ride i have no no
i've ridden uh quite a lot in various
movies and stuff and you know growing up
in kentucky you grow up around horses
and everything but every horse is
different
so yeah so you had to ride that horse at
top speed quite a lot yeah how did that
go
went pretty well up into a point yeah
there was one moment in particular where
it got unpleasant where
the horses had been running we'd been
running them all day so
they weren't really uh interested in
slowing down
at all so we went to we're shooting at a
different place in the desert where
there's these you know their little
bumps and
things growing and
and so my horse
that i was on decided to jump a couple
of these little obstacles
horse was unaware that the
saddle i was wearing to sit on top of it
was
sort of jerry-rigged kind of faked it's
it was to give the effect that you were
riding bareback the horse to get the
effect on riding bareback so basically
it wasn't it's not really tight on the
horse it's just enough to yeah just a
little tissue there for you
a band-aid
and uh so yeah when we came down
i went to the saddle slipped you know
and i went to the left and had the reins
here
and
somehow had the wherewithal to grab the
mane of the horse and then the next
thing i saw all very calm for some
reason i i figured that fear would kick
in but it didn't
i was waiting
i i just all i saw were in front of my
eyes were this sort of these very
muscular horse legs the striations
the striations of muscles moving you
know
it's kind of death machine
[Music]
and
one word popped into my head
hooves
you know
hooves
in any case
hooves yeah
find the hooves so what do you do when
you're in that position well you make a
decision
will i go with the beast until someone
wrangles it
or will i drop
you know we'll you know it's a crap
shoot sure
and what did you choose i dropped you
dropped
now when you